[Aplausos]
desde pequena
provavelmente quando tinha 19 anos minha
família me perguntava o que eu queria
fazer quando crescesse eu respondi eu
quero mudar o mundo
o ponto dessa resposta nunca foi o
desafio dessa resposta nunca foi a
grandiosidade disso ea intensidade disso
mas sempre como eu poderia fazer isso e
é a primeira vez que eu tive algumas
idéias de como fazer isso surgiu numa
sala de aula quando meu professor de
finanças chegou no primeiro dia e fez a
seguinte pergunta por que escolhemos os
dentes todos os dias
nunca ninguém tinha feito esse
questionamento pra mim e honestamente
você já pode pensar nisso porque você
escova os dentes todos os dias
a pergunta a resposta foi tão óbvia
quanto à pergunta
ele só fala assim porque nos ensinaram
que esse é um hábito saudável que esse
gene pessoal
logo em seguida ele perguntou assim
porque precisamos trabalhar todos os
dias
de novo parecia meio óbvio pra nossa
sala inteira e e é importante pensar que
o que você aprende em casa
como que você responderia a essa
pergunta ele deu outra resposta óbvia
como qualquer professor porque
precisamos ganhar dinheiro e não estava
na aula de finanças não é mesmo
pois é a questão é será que é só isso
tirando a parte socióloga dessa resposta
será que é só porque nós precisamos
ganhar dinheiro não é em todos os
lugares não é bem assim
aqui no brasil a gente aprende desde
cedo pelo menos na minha casa e em
vários jovens eu conheço que nós
precisamos crescer estudar e trabalhar
para ganhar dinheiro para ganhar
dinheiro e sustentar
pois é não é não é sempre assim
um grande exemplo disso é que lá nos
estados unidos
é um pouquinho diferente às crianças lá
desde casa aprendem a importância de
poupar investir e se planejar
financeiramente por exemplo eu tenho um
primo que acabou de nascer nos estados
unidos ele só tem um ano e o avô paterno
dele que é americano o primeiro presente
que lhe deu pra ele
foi um título de tesouro nacional dos
estados unidos
por que ele fez isso porque ele falou
que quando gustavo crescesse aos 18 anos
fosse o primeiro investimento para ele
aplicar na faculdade dele quando ele
precisar se bem diferente daqui né que
acredita que um dos primeiros presentes
fraldas
então não é sempre assim e pode ser
diferente se você ainda não entendeu o
porquê meu professor de finanças e ainda
essa pergunta do porquê escovamos os
dentes todos os dias ou mais na situação
é um sábado à noite e você está se
arrumando para sair provavelmente se
você for jovem em uma balada se você for
mais velho por outro jantar ou vice
versa porque hoje em dia isso não é
regra né
e aí você no processo de se arrumar você
escova os dentes ou pelo menos eu espero
que sim
tirando uma amiga minha que pode passar
uma hora os combatentes que ela está
feliz
a maioria de nós faz isso porque é um
hábito de higiene pessoal mesmo
e exatamente isso que o professor queria
dizer é um hábito é um hábito que nos
ensinaram desde crianças que isso fazia
parte da nossa e iene pessoal e por que
então se planejar financeiramente não é
um hábito de higiene financeira porque
nós não aprendemos isso desde casa a
importância de se planejar
financeiramente pois é você não posta
uma foto no facebook escovando os dentes
e disse que aquela foi a melhor parte do
seu sábado à noite na mesmo assim como
você não vai achar parte mais divertida
da sua noite ou da sua semana se
planejar financeiramente gerenciar o seu
dinheiro
você não vai fazer isso
mas é importante que a gente aprenda a
importância de criar esse hábito desde
casa desde casa e depois nas escolas não
é mesmo
pois é pensando em tudo isso e vendo a
importância disso eu e mais cinco amigos
fundamos na universidade federal de
santa catarina uma liga universitária e
uma empresa júnior de mercado financeiro
e que tinha com o seguinte slogan
investir no conhecimento para locar
lucrar no resultado
nós fizemos isso pra exatamente criar
uma ponte entre a universidade eo
mercado financeiro
afinal nenhum de nós tínhamos aprendido
sobre mercado financeiro nem em casa e
nem na escola e cinco de nós éramos
engenheiros e só um economista
então nós vimos o quanto é importante
aprender sobre isso e para cada um
essa importância do planejamento
financeiro pode ser diferente
pode ser para comprar sua casa própria
pode ser até o carro que você quiser os
18 anos pode fazer pode ser aquela
planejado a viagem dos sonhos ou pode
ser até brincar com a minha mãe lá em
casa não sei vocês mas a minha mas
sempre falou pra mim
joana por acaso até é sócia da celesc
porque solução quarta seja de novo que
eu vivia deixando as luzes acesas e
assim que eu aprendi sobre mercado
financeiro da bolsa de valores
uma das primeiras coisas que eu fui
pesquisar o preço da ação da celesc que
eu percebi que eu podia ser só se assim
e aí eu podia ter um argumento ali com
ela mas tirando tudo isso tirando a
importância pessoal de cada um como
grupo
nós tínhamos um objetivo maior
por exemplo observa esse gráfico aqui
alguém de vocês já os gráficos
quantos de vocês sabem interpretar o que
é esse gráfico
quantos de vocês conhecem pessoas que
sabem o que é esse gráfico ou melhor
quantos de vocês conhecem pessoas na
faixa etária de 20 anos que sabem que
esse gráfico
pois é
eu acho que a resposta agora vai ser
poucas pouquíssimas né pelo menos outros
vão surpreender mas a maioria das vezes
a resposta é bem poucas
eu mesmo não sabia o que era isso e tudo
isso não seja num passe de mágica como
que isso aconteceu
o grupo tinha sempre o objetivo de que a
resposta daquele gráfico ali fosse maior
daqui a 10 anos que daqui a dez anos a
gente esteja nessa mesma sala ou na
universidade federal em florianópolis a
gente pergunte se alguém sabe
interpretar aquele gráfico e muita gente
saiba o melhor tenha pessoas e mais
pessoas ensinando sobre aquilo lá e como
tudo isso aconteceu
bom eu tinha 19 anos fazendo engenharia
e eu que assim tive uma dúvida que quase
nenhum jovem que eu tô fazendo a minha
vida que eu tô fazendo a minha vida que
eu quero para minha carreira que eu vou
trabalhar no futuro pois é pensando isso
uma amiga minha falou assim humana tem
umas palestras de carreira em são paulo
você deveria participar eu convidei um
amigo meu
nós vamos até são paulo para assistir às
palestras de carreira no mercado
financeiro que não entende absolutamente
nada
chegando lá um pouquinho antes das
palestras começarem é eles fizeram uma
dinâmica com a sala bem simples favor
apresente seu nome da onde vem o que
está fazendo e nessa palestra a maioria
das jovens eram de são paulo e eles
respondiam que eles faziam parte de
ligas universitárias de mercado
financeiro
eu meu amigo a gente ficou muito
curiosos sobre o que era isso
nos intervalos a gente vai conversar com
essas pessoas para se informar o que
tinha uma liga de mercado financeiro que
é uma liga universitária
eles falaram pra gente quer um grupo de
jovens que se reunia na faculdade para
aprender sobre finanças
quando a gente voltou para florianópolis
a gente venceu cara a gente precisa
levar isso pra floripa
pois é com quem já falei isso né ele foi
lá e fez
buck queremos fundar um grupo de estudos
sobre finanças alguém interessado
naquela mesma semana a gente marcou a
primeira reunião no início que
apareceram 12 pessoas no final de três
reuniões que nós fizemos no alinhamento
de expectativas
ou seja o que cada um esperava daquele
grupo
nós ficamos em 6 e essas seis pessoas
foi exatamente a nossa inteira que assim
deu uma idéia dentro da universidade
essas seis pessoas juntas fundaram uma
liga universitária empresa júnior de
mercado financeiro ou seja a gente não
queria acessar um grupo que estudasse
sobre isso
nós queremos ser um grupo que aplicasse
isso na prática que fizesse networking
com as empresas que pudesse aplicar
consultoria júnior para empresas e
negócios ao nosso redor
para aplicar tudo aquilo que a gente
estava aprendendo na liga universitária
e junto com isso outros trabalhar
trabalho da nossa liga universitária era
transmitir esse conhecimento por isso
investir no conhecimento e lucrar no
resultado
ali se descobriu que o maior segredo de
tudo isso era compartilhar as idéias
então não basta só ir lá e estudar as
interessadas sobre o assunto porque um
segredo do conhecimento é quando ele é
compartilhado como que a gente fazia
isso
a gente ia lá se capacitaram
internamente
leia se nós montávamos palestras para
nós mesmos
assim é quatro vezes por semana nós nos
reunimos montavam as palestras ensinavam
que quer economia para o outro porque
dentro do grupo
são pessoas que sabiam mais pessoas que
sabiam - então nós queríamos nos nivelar
e depois de um ou dois meses disso nós
começamos a fazer os nossos primeiro
eventos
então a gente gostava no facebook que ia
ter uma palestra sobre o que é a bolsa
de valores o que é aquele gráfico que eu
acabei de mostrar pra vocês
a gente reúne nos nossos eventos em
média
60 a 120 pessoas 120 estudantes que
vinham pra aprender sobre o que é
finanças
qual a importância de se planejar
financeiramente e isso brilhava os
nossos olhos
pois é o grupo existe até hoje
logo após isso nós fizemos os nossos
primeiros processos seletivos que
entraram mais pessoas engajadas
nós éramos a única empresa júnior da
ufsc que aceitava pessoas de qualquer
curso qualquer curso com um único pré
requisito para entrar dentro do grupo
ter vontade de aprender e ter vontade de
aprender sobre mercado financeiro porque
o segredo é compartilhar nisso nós
fizemos diversos eventos que nós
chamamos responsáveis de empresas de
finanças
nós mesmos temos diversas palestras
entramos em contato com professores
fizemos at work com todas aquelas ligas
universitárias que tinham em são paulo e
o grupo existe até hoje
hoje em dia o grupo continua se
desenvolvendo continua ganhando espaço
na universidade continua fazendo sucesso
e continua aprendendo e compartilhando o
conhecimento ea importância da educação
financeira preparando alguns para entrar
nesse mercado preparando outros para
planejar os sonhos futuros e preparando
alguns só para compartilharem
conhecimentos como eu estou fazendo aqui
hoje o que motivou também palavrinha bem
simples chamada entusiasmo
eu não sabia absolutamente nada de
mercado financeiro nada nem o que era
aquele gráfico e muito menos aqui é uma
ação
eu não sabia nada a gente não tinha
dinheiro a gente não tinha professores
que apostavam nessa ideia a gente só
tinha entusiasmo e nós mesmos ea gente
foi lá e fez alguma coisa acontecer pois
é
e falando de entusiasmo faleceu no mês
passado um grande cientista que deixou
um legado enorme para o nosso mundo não
é mesmo
se forem hawking
e ele falou a seguinte frase lembre se
de olhar para as estrelas lá em cima e
não para os seus pés aqui embaixo
tente entender o que vê e refeita porque
o universo existe
seja curioso e por mais que a vida
parecia difícil há sempre algo que você
pode fazer e ter sucesso
o importante é simplesmente não desistir
ele deixa um legado enorme pra nossa
ciência e ele não conseguia nem falar a
gente o que a gente pode fazer tem de
todas as suas habilidades ou não pois é
eu ainda não descobri como mudar o mundo
porque eu ainda vou mas eu sei que o meu
mundo mudou o mundo das pessoas à minha
volta também mudou
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]